with the flashback on TV let's take a
look at ten things you probably didn't
know about the Scarlet speedster show
according to the show's casting director
David Rappaport before Grant Gustin was
cast as Barry Allen on the flash he
auditioned to play Thea Queens boyfriend
in the first season of arrow and Andy
Mientus who brings to life the
villainous Pied Piper on the flash
initially read for the role of the
Scarlet speedster oh and by the way
Robbie Amell who plays Ronnie Raymond
one half of firestorm originally
auditioned for Oliver Queen on arrow
though of course that role went to
Stephen Amell Robbie's cousin storyboard
artist
Adrian Van verson made over 400 boards
for the flash pilot compared to only
half that number for the arrow pilot
according to Van vias and the flash is
the biggest pilot he and director David
Nutter have ever worked on together and
bear in mind they've made pilots for
shows including arrow Smallville and
Terminator the Sarah Connor Chronicles
the flash is particularly complex as a
stunt and visual effects teams have to
combine the Speed Force effects with the
live action and the storyboards are
especially useful for that about
one-sixth of the show is computer
animated and in the pilot there are
about 200 visual effects production
designer Tyler Heron based the look of
the show's particle accelerator set on
the Large Hadron Collider though the set
is obviously a lot smaller at just 40
foot by 20 foot also the treadmill that
Barry Allen runs on at STAR Labs was
actually built from scratch for the show
and can go up to 16 miles an hour in an
interview at PaleyFest Grant Gustin said
that at some point in the future the
STAR Labs treadmill will become the
cosmic treadmill which in the DC Comics
Barrie used to travel through time if
you've ever wondered just what the
metahumans locked up under STAR Labs ate
a deleted scene from season 1 episode 21
Grodd lives revealed the answer
according to Caitlin snow the weather
wizard is a Thai food fiend Picabo just
loves
enchiladas and death bolt is a vegan and
dr. snow didn't say who they were but
judging by her food trolley there were
quite a few big belly burger fans down
there - speaking of big belly burger the
fictional fast-food chain which appears
in both the flash and arrow TV shows
first appeared in DC Comics back in June
1988 in issue 441 of The Adventures of
Superman the big belly burger of the
comic books was founded in Coast City
and is a subsidiary of Lex Luthor's Lex
Corp and was actually inspired by the
real-life big boy restaurant chain
composer Blake Neely who scores both the
flash and arrow included a special
musical Easter egg and tricksters
episode 17 of the first season in the
episode Mark Hamill he appeared in the
original live-action TV series of the
flash in the early 1990s returns as a
villainous James jesse aka the trickster
so Blake nearly used composer Shirlee
Walker's trickster theme which he wrote
and conducted for the 1990s show and
Hamill isn't the only actor from that
early flash show to make a comeback veto
D'Ambrosio who played police officer
Anthony bellows in the original show
returned as the same character for
seasons 1 and 2 of the new show though
this time he's mayor of Central City
actress Amanda pays also returned a
scientist dr. Tina McGee and John Wesley
Shipp who plays Barry Allen's father
actually starred as a Scarlet speedster
in the original series actor Jesse L
Martin's character detective Joe West
doesn't actually exist in the comics in
the comics irises father is either the
scientist IRA West or the alcoholic
William West but despite the fact Joe
West was created especially for the TV
series he almost didn't even make it to
the second episode as the creators were
considering killing him off in the pilot
and if you've ever wondered why Joe is
often seen wearing a black beanie it was
Jesse L Martin's idea partly to give Joe
a bit of a different look to NYPD
detective ed green who Martin played on
TVs Law & Order for nearly a decade if
you've seen the musical
and though the beanie may remind you of
Marta's character in that
grodd's cage very nearly didn't make it
into the show's pilot due to the cost of
building it later when Grodd himself
appeared on screen unlike Peter
Jackson's King Kong or the recent Planet
of the Apes movies the show did not use
performance capture to bring its
sizeable simian star to life instead
visual effects supervisor armand
Kevorkian and his crew at encore VFX
built Grodd from scratch on the computer
creating his skeleton then adding
muscles and then skin and fur the show's
executives first gave Kevorkian the
heads-up soon after finishing the pilots
that Grodd was going to feature in
season 1 the inspiration on grodd's
design the visual effects crew looked at
the comic books for his size and
attitude and at videos of real gorillas
- Kevorkian also roughly acted out
grodd's moves and facial expressions for
the animators who sometimes also
recorded themselves to check out what
did and didn't work the presence onset
of a stunt actor in a large Grodd suit
and stilts provided further inspiration
for the gorillas actions and also helped
the crew frame each shot just as the
Flash's speed has increased over the
course of the series the race at which
the show is shot has also sped up for
example in the early days they'd need 20
to 30 takes to film a straightforward
shot of the flash running but now they
often get what they need in just a
couple of tapes when Grant Gustin first
started putting on his flash costume it
took him a whole 40 minutes to suit up
mainly because his mask had to be glued
to his face however after episode 8 of
season 1 Gaston got a new mask that
looks the same but slides on with a
zipper which means it now only takes
from a speedy ten to 15 minutes to slip
into his superhero suit the original
costume which is mostly made of leather
with some added stretchy material for
ease of movement was designed by :
Atwood Maya mani who designed arrow
season for suit is behind the changes to
the Flash's season - costume which harks
back to the comic books with its emblem
featuring a lightning bolt on white
rather than red background now let me
know in the comments below
who are your favorite characters on the
flash and what other characters from the
comics would you like to see on the show
if you enjoyed this video do please
share it hit the thumbs-up button and
subscribe for more things you didn't
know as well as movie reviews and
interviews thanks for watching UPI ATV
lovers